so let us say it again wearing a mask
can save a life during this pandemic but
some americans refuse to wear them
this video shows one man's rage in a
florida costco after an elderly woman
asked him to wear a mask
similar scenes have played out across
the country in texas where cases are
skyrocketing
a growing number of sheriff's
departments are refusing to enforce
mandatory mass orders janet chameleon
reports from san antonio
people just wanted a hug and i i told
them look you're adults you make your
own
choices but now pastor ron arba is full
of regret
after allowing members to embrace when
his church calvary chapel in universal
city texas
reopened in may more than 50 people who
were there have coronavirus
including arba's wife and the pastor
himself
i wish i could go back and make a
different decision now but
unfortunately i can't do that our boss
says only about half his congregants
were wearing masks
it was well before governor greg
abbott's mandate to wear them
that order now allows authorities to
find repeat offenders
as much as 250 dollars for not wearing a
face covering in public spaces indoors
or outdoors where social distancing
isn't possible
violators can't be jailed or detained
and police in several counties have said
they will not enforce the ruling
we're asking we're asking for
self-compliance from our citizens
nacogdoches sheriff jason bridges says
he doesn't want to write citations
but deputies will remind people of the
order
we believe in science we're not
anti-mask
our jail staff has been wearing masks
back in the jail since this thing has
started
we have seen the prevention of what it's
helped keep the coronavirus out of the
nicodose county jail so
we know that it works but mess continued
to be a divisive issue
on tuesday the texas education agency
announced it will require masks for
teachers
and students older than 10 who attend
in-person classes this fall
some parents are opposed to it but
everyone should get used to it
says the ceo of the texas medical center
we're the only ones that can stop it so
really
masking is not a weak deal or a couple
of months
we're going to be wearing masks for a
very long period of time
some of the sheriff's refusing to
enforce the mask order say they simply
don't have the resources to do so
here along the riverwalk in san antonio
there was a mass quarter in effect
well before the governor's order when
social distancing is a pile
is not possible rather and if you walk
along here every store gale
and business that you go into has a sign
on the door stating it clearly
no mask no service gail
yes like no shoes no service we get it
no shirt it's such a small thing
thank you very much janet good to see
you too